Alex you say that when you commit to a
script that you pretty much read it
every day yeah what are you doing every
day with that script how are you
digesting it
how are you processing it I just try to
read it once a day from the first of the
last page on and there's no really
there's no real strategy or I don't have
a there's just more by reading it once a
day I feel like I things happen and I
come up with thoughts and ideas and and
I'll discover something even if it's the
55th time I read the script there's
something else I'll discover something
or come up with in an idea for the
character or idea for a specific scene
or it could be something more general on
and then a lot of those ideas are
terrible and but by doing that at least
like it's something starts a kind of a
an internal creative process where and
then it's more about filter out those
99% of bad ideas and then holding on to
those ones that you think are actually
good for the foundation of the character
in a way so yeah it's just the way I
prepare it I guess
you've also said that you like playing
characters that have both darkness and
light why well because I think we all do
that we all have that and that's what
being a human being is all about and
that dichotomy and if I don't subscribe
to good versus evil and you know it's it
works in a in if it's like a it just
becomes very kind of when it comes to
real human beings I don't think we're
there's a case of good versus evil I
think we're all capable of good and bad
deeds and what makes good drama is that
internal struggle that internal conflict
and I just don't think it would be fun
to play a character that was all evil or
good because you want to feel that
inside that little struggle and in this
case this was a character who was when
when I first read his script he's
clearly not it could easily been just a
villain a bad guy someone preying on
this teenager and that is what got me
excited cuz I felt like well how do I
come on make that how can I make this
interesting and how can I find something
not necessarily likable but at least
like that people can understand and
relate to in him and because then that's
what makes it interesting and I think
when I watch movies myself it's always
more interesting if it's complex and a
bit complicated where you're like I want
to like this guy but what don't I or I
don't want to like him by suddenly like
I like him in this moment that's when it
becomes real and it gives it life Minnie
and Monroe seem simpatico even though
there's a 20-year age difference how are
they similar well I think that was the
next step when I when I felt like well
he's without condoning what he does he's
how can I make him real and how can I
make it give a depth and I think a way
of doing that was to see him as a
teenager in moments I think that will
make give give many and Monroe a real
connection because I think believe that
there are moments where he feels like a
15 year old boy and that connection is
really strong and they're really in love
but then he pulls himself out of it
intentionally or sometimes
unintentionally and realizes I don't
know I'm a grown up I this is I got to
be responsible this is not right and and
there are moments where she's more
responsible and and than he is and
that's what gives it life that journey
their their relationship and I think in
many ways he has a stronger connection
with her than he does with his with her
mother that's his age
thank you